[Musique]
depuis plusieurs mois nous il m'arrive
de téléporter dans le futur oui je sais
mais j'ai tellement c'est pas être à
bout jure que c'est vrai et dans ce
futur on autour des choses particulières
et aujourd'hui j'aimerais vraiment voulu
partager et peut-être qu'ensemble on
arrive à une certaine réflexion je vous
laisserai tout le temps file toute votre
vie après pour y réfléchir
et j'aime simplement tout transmettre
tous ces messages que je que j'ai eu du
futur par exemple un futur on entend des
choses étranges comme l'amour c'est une
émotion ou si la vie si je suis pas
gentille clavier leur âge il est pas
gentil avec moi que les carreaux c'est
bien mais si on peut pas les partager
avec des gens qu'on aime avoir ne
servent à rien et même que réussir c'est
d'être aimé des autres et vous savez qui
n'a passé ce genre de message et bien
c'est être de futurs sont comme vous et
moi sans distinction différentes deux
bras deux jambes
encore un coeur en parfait état nargis
au cerveau qui marche très bien aussi
la seule différence c'est que ce sont
des enfants entre 6 et 10 ans dès lors
j'ai quelques questions à vous poser est
ce que vous avez déjà pris le temps
d'observer en bouffant pour de vrai
est-ce que vous avez déjà essayé de vous
mettre juste à sa place ou peut-être
même essayé de penser comme lui quand il
se met en colère ou quand il a peur
quand il a du chagrin
évidemment vous en ayant toutes ces
questions et bien évidemment que je les
écoute mon enfant je suis ça toute la
journée
ou alors ouais ça va assez bien c'est un
enfant aille vers la cantine
la réalité c'est cet enfant a vraiment
sa propre façon penser ses propres aux
clients et vous accuse qui est devant
moi sans juger vraiment personne le
inconsciemment vous mettez cette enfant
dans une boîte une terrasse la vôtre
tout ça par vos croyances limitantes
votre votre éducation
mais cet enfant est un être à part
entière il a des choses à me dire ils
arrivent à penser par lui-même à
ressentir les choses par lui même à ses
propres vignes dans les ateliers du
futur que j'anime oui parce qu'en plus
je suis animatrice dans les ateliers du
futur ces ateliers s'appelle les
ateliers philo et pendant ces moments
suspendus et bien on avait vraiment à
partager ensemble et les enfants
partagent et échangent discutent tout
autour toujours autour d'un tel est son
aile des écrans d'internet de la télé si
si je vous jure que ça existe dans le
futur et aujourd'hui cet enfant est là
et il arrive vraiment à le voir sa
liberté d'être à s'autoriser à exprimer
ce qu'il veut pour que tout cela
fonctionne il faut prendre deux choses
deux valeurs fondamentales en tout cas à
mon sens le respect et l'amour
tout d'abord le respect les enfants se
respectent beaucoup plus de bon sens je
trouve que les adultes
je vais vous donner c'est même de grand
stade et je vais même vous donner en
exemple cet exemple je les ai pris de
rage les retire dans l'atelier futur et
on était avec des enfants il avait entre
8 et 10 ans et ses enfants on était on
avait choisi une question qui s'était à
quoi ça sert un doudou et donc ils ont
commencé à réfléchir à poser à échanger
entre eux à partager et pendant j'ai pas
cinq minutes c'était très convivial et
dans ce bouquin petit bonhomme qui
s'appelle les eaux qui s'est mis à
pleurer mais plus réac feux de la rampe
et moi ce que j'ai fait moi adultes des
formations professionnelles peut-être
j'essaye de le calmer
la question est là il nous explique il
avait perdu son doudou qu'à trois ans où
il avait 5 ans et qu'il n'était jamais
remis j'ai tous les enfants étaient là
elles regardaient et et subtile de même
il était inconsolable
et qu'est ce que les autres ont fait est
bien mieux là lui faire des câlins
anglais d'aller vraiment réconforter
l'endiguer mais tu sais on peut en
traiter un doudou quand même moi je peux
tout en étant donné les mêmes on a un cv
d aimer si on lui en fabriquer un
[Musique]
et à ce moment là je les ai vraiment
conserver et j'ai fait qu'ils allaient
cette bienveillance idées en eux ils ont
vraiment ils ont vraiment cette profonde
bienveillance que qui peuvent nous
apporter que nous aussi adultes on peut
leur apporter
pour moi c'est la clé les relations
humaines mais déjà revenons sur le thème
de la bienveillance qu'est ce que c'est
la viande et d'os
c'est elle déjà qui à la mode en ce
moment un peu comme la chefferie spyder
millions la bienveillance séparer 30
bisounours
ce ne pas être ce n'est pas dire dire
oui à tout non pour ma part la
bienveillance sassard implique une
affirmation mais une affirmation fondée
sur le respect d'autrui mais pour que
tout cela fonctionne aussi il faut y
associer la deuxième heure qui est
l'amour les enfants adorent parler de
l'amour
et moi j'adore les écouter et j'adore
parler d'eux
et pendant ces moments où il partage
dans l'amour et sur l'excusé de l'amour
et bien ils sont sans filtre ils sont
authentiques
une petite fille a même illustré l'amour
que c'est à pouvait se donné entre un
homme et une femme entre deux hommes ou
entre deux femmes c'était vraiment une
authenticité flagrante un enfant bien
d'affaires de distinction peau de
couleur de peau en tout cas jusqu'à ce
que l'adulte une influence ils ont leur
liberté d'être il s'autorise à être sans
filtre simple je vais vous donner un
exemple mais au râtelier film il ya
quelques mois quelques semaines je suis
parti à new york et j'étais assis sur
les marches dans l'oubli célèbre il
faisait très beau c'était vraiment une
journée splendide
il y avait rejeté sur les marges il ya
un saxophoniste de rues qui étaient là
et qui jouait parfaitement bien et
j'écoutais roumois dame au manteau de
demandes de modifications de tout ce que
j'avais entendu les pas comme pas
chanter faux etc
alors je suis le froid de l'est dans ma
tête je ne voulais absolument pas être
jugé je ne voulais pas qu'on m'entende
et tout à coup sûr la gauche
un groupe d'enfants est arrivé il allait
traverser et ils ont écouté forcément
ils ont entendu le saxophoniste 2 est
bien quand il fait d'après vous eh bien
ils se sont mis à chanter à danser un
livre arrive sans se soucier du regard
des autres et j'ai observé cette scène
il était le verbe il s'autorisait à être
donc j'en ai conclu que quand on
distribue de l'amour de la bienveillance
du respect et bien rond distribue aussi
des sourires
c'est vraiment un monde 7 c'est vraiment
été des moments où je vis dans une
lettre
extrêmement puissants sans amour
déprimant mais absolument rien et lance
les enfants nous compris lors d'un autre
atelier avec des toupies si des six ans
on allait vraiment j'en avais vraiment
aussi parlé bien lourd mais un petit
boulot m'a dit écoutez grill comme elle
perd une chose tu sais tout le monde a
besoin d'amour effectivement mais tout
le monde a besoin d'amour et il m'a dit
tu sais les sdf qui dorment dans la rue
ceux qui sont tous seuls et là ils ont
pas d'amour et puis les gens qui passent
devant les lords a pas d'amour oui moi
adultes ok ai dit tu sais comment ils
peuvent trouver de l'amoureux nous
aimons et nous répond tu es ma répondu
eh bien il va prendre un petit compagnon
un chien le ca il aura de l'amour est il
fini en me disant parce que sans amour
on meurt à ce moment là ça m'a retourné
je suis resté scotché sur la chaîne il
m'a touché en plein coeur ce petit
bonhomme et il avait raison
c'est vraiment des des enfants
extraordinaires mais une des expériences
qui m'apprit touché et qui me touchent
au plus profond de mon coeur depuis des
années même sexe l'aise ces êtres du
futur en quelque chose que nous on a pas
que l'on s'autorise pas nous a great il
s'autorise arrivée les enfants des
règles même beaucoup plus grand que ça
les aide à se construire à se réaliser à
être eux-mêmes et donc en parlant des
rêves eh bien je leur ai posé une
question est ce que vous croyez que tous
les rêves peuvent être
réaliser j'avais très peur de leurs
épouses et j'avais très peur aussi de me
faire éjecter de ce futur enfant
verifone évidemment et m'ont dit oui
effectivement tous les rêves peuvent
être réalisées absolument tous
si on nous laisse la liberté d'être et
de pouvoir rêver à ce qu'on veut de
pouvoir rêver à ce pauvre
alors j'ai osé leur voler une liste en
tout cas un échantillon de leur liste
des rêves et vous allez voir qu'elle se
faisait plutôt ce que vous allez
entendre n'est pas du tout la liste à
laquelle vous attendez on est loin de la
liste au père noël
oui effectivement j'ai même eu les
dessins par exemple le montant
j'aurai le prends l'avion je rêve d'une
chambre moi tout seul je rêve de jouer
tout le temps je rêve de ne plus aller à
l'école
je rêve que tous les rêves se réalisent
mais aussi remontant je rêve que mes
parents jouent plus avec moi je rêve que
la planète a eu mieux
je rêve que les gens soient plus gentils
entre eux je rêve que mon meilleur ami
reviennent en france karine blank
je rêve que les parents se remettent
ensemble
je rêve que ma maman guérisse de sa
maladie et qu'elle compte réalisme vous
voyez la liste on peut leur arriver
alors après avoir recensé toutes leurs
réflexions toutes leurs pensées
je me suis intéressé à leur mode de
fonctionnement week au foot il sait être
du futur pour penser de cette façon dont
y aurait trois clés je dirais les trois
qui est fondamental de cette réflexion
et de ses pensées la universal
premièrement par la pratique de la
pension pendant cette pratique de la
tension les enfants se connecte à halle
sont en pleine conscience ce dépôt lui
de leur agitation mental comme tout le
monde ici au quotidien se connectent à
leur âme s'autorise s'exprime et tous à
la plus grande bienveillance deuxième
clé il s'autorise à s'exprimer et à
rêver le bonheur est dans les rêves qui
se réalisent il les enfants du couple
ont compris et troisièmement pour
pouvoir s'exprimer arriver il faut
prendre en compte une attitude positive
j'ai une question à vous poser vous en
aller par là voudraient plutôt
spectateur qu'acteur de votre vie elle
permet aussi d'être en permanence brill
polluée par des briseurs de rêves
le bonheur est ce vraiment là dans mes
rêves qui fraises et les enfants nous
compris et aujourd'hui j'aimerais
vraiment vous autoriser à être je suis
extrêmement chanceuse de passer ces
moments dans le futur je suis d aller
retour et aujourd'hui il ya quelques
jours il était avec moi et je leur ai
dit que j'étais là et je leur ai dit et
m'ont dit tu peut alors passer un
message a eu là donc je vous passe leur
message et je suis extrêmement fier de
vous partager
et c'est ce livre j'ai au fond de moi
aussi depuis longtemps dans ma vie ils
m'ont dit si on grince grand écho
visualise tous les jours semaines et
bien un jour x riez et pour qu'il se
réalise eh bien il faut s'autoriser à
être et à devenir alors je terminerai en
vous posant deux dernières questions
vous grands enfants que vous êtes ici là
devant moi parce que vous êtes tous des
grands enfants déjà quand est-ce que
vous avez joué pour la dernière fois les
deux dernières question c'est qu'est ce
qui vous empêche aujourd'hui de rêver
grand et qui ou quoi vous empêcherait
vraiment de le faire merci
[Applaudissements]